[Musique]
en france 11 millions de personnes
aident régulièrement un membre de leur
famille en situation de handicap en
perte d'autonomie à domicile
la troisième édition du salon hitomi se
penche sur les problématiques de
l'accessibilité et de la perte de
l'autonomie
pour aider les personnes en situation de
handicap ou en perte d'autonomie mais
aussi que les aidants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on soit garez vous
bonjour vous êtes le président d'une vie
comment est née it only via autonomie a
été créée d'abord on a créé une vie
sains et une vie c est ferré un peu le
sens pont entre les entreprises les
structures de formation les patients
tels et les futurs employés et à partir
de là
un partage une vie on a réfléchi
complètement surtout problème du grand
âge et tout problème de l'autonomie et à
un moment donné on se nous sommes dit
pourquoi il ya trois ans nous devrions
pas un salon de l'autonomie et notamment
avec comment le numérique pourrait être
utile pour les notions de dépendance et
le grand âge
vous avez créé également le hub
d'autonomie buy-in vie des chemins à
favoriser l'autonomie des personnes
âgées et les personnes en situation de
handicap
concrètement quelles actions dans
l'europe si le g si vous voulez
le point important aujourd'hui il est
évident que quand on revient dans les
années futures
30 % de la population en eau en ondes
aura plus de 60 ans 12% aura plus de 75
ans et 5 % plus de 85 ans
donc le problème de l'autonomie va
devenir de plus en plus prégnant c'est
pour cela qu'il faut qu'il y ait les
structures comme un hub
dans lequel on réfléchisse à comment on
peut aider à l'automne
c'est la troisième édition du
occasion pour plusieurs filières
professionnelles
jal domotique route
si 200 exposants sont présents sur
sociale ont ils sont regroupés au sein
quelles sont les thématiques alors si
aujourd'hui dans la thématique
premièrement la mobilité
c'est important parce que si on
oui c'est comment je prenais un nous
voir
deuxième sujet aussi et qui est
important c'est l'autonomie
certes obama par exemple je suis chez
moi je veux manger je veux le déplacer
troisième sujet aussi c'est comment
éventuellement avec tout ce qui nous
entoure
aussi bien le numérique aussi bien les
énergies c'est comme je vais être
capable de les utiliser et comment
éventuellement même si je suis dépendant
on assurera pour moi l'entraînement
c'est indépendance
annoncé m comme usager aucun de mes
occupations les visiteurs passionnés à
des conférences des
monstration
terme de démonstration on a déjà tout un
ensemble de raymond station sur comment
se mouvoir sans virer les automates
deuxièmement aussi par exemple il est
une start up qui est l'un qui va
démontrer aussi comment éventuellement
dans son domicile et dans sa maison on
peut surveiller complètement l'ensemble
des énergies savoir si j'aime
et un troisième point aussi il ya
beaucoup de conférences aussi sur des
sujets comme par exemple un designer
comme éventuellement la dépendance
pantale la dépendance visuel mais aussi
il est important de travailler aussi sur
la notion d' aide à la personne et
comment je peux quand j'ai quelqu'un
handicap quand j'ai quelqu'un qui est
dépendant c'est comment je travaille
avec lui donc c'est tout cela donne en
hausse y aura une vente conférence par
myriam el khomri qui a été chargé
justement par le ministère de réfléchir
aux métiers du grand talent et de mal de
temps à ses premières conclusions et
demain après midi
il assure que les terres d'état au
handicap sera présent avec les
présidents des conseils départementaux
des idées des autres
envoyée c'est un sujet d'intérêt général
un sujet à la fois locales régionales
mais c'est un sujet
deux sociétés la 3ème édition du salon
marque le lancement officiel du social
en quoi ça consiste bano sociale là
aujourd'hui il va y avoir plusieurs
sujets qui vous souhaitez emploie déjà
éveillé mon village dans lequel on va
travailler les mobilités il ya un
deuxième travail aussi qui va se faire
avec tout un ensemble d'entreprises de
start up etc pour voir comment on peut
participer notamment à la presse qu'on
appelle la patientèle on va dire les
usagers alors leur confort et troisième
fois aussi c'est surtout par rapport à
sociale celle là c'est se met en
situation telle que le vivre les gens
aujourd'hui qui sont en situation de
dépendance
quels sont les porteurs pour produits
sains compagnie parle de ce soir alors
monsieur vous avez de nombreux porteurs
il ya aussi bien des universités aussi
bien des institutions entreprises des
institutions de type
par exemple les conseils et dans les
conseils départementaux vous avez
les unités de recherche vous avez aussi
des petites entreprises
mais je crois que c'est un doux
bien évidemment avec aussi les
entreprises qui travaillent pour la
tournée de la personne qui travaille
aussi pour pouces qui est l'invité de la
dépendance
donc c'est vraiment un tout et c'est
l'intérêt d'un social
c'est là ça sera le lieu de naissance de
la coordination de texture
[Musique]
très 2,3 millions de personnes souffrent
d'une limitation physique ou mental plus
de 100 exposants sont ici pour la
troisième édition du salon hit onomie
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir leurs
solutions et leur dispositif
la réalité virtuelle c'est vraiment bien
j'évite des bobos qui communiquent avec
nous et qui parle avec nous c'est
vraiment bien parce qu est-ce qui va
marquer c'est le petit robot qui j'ai vu
ou vous lancer le label rouge et par
rapport au déplacement je pense c'est
par rapport au ca la couleur donc là il
se déplace il voit mal la balle donc je
pense que dans le futur
c'est plutôt pour la pauvre pour vous me
posez une question va me chercher une
cuillère il va voir venir la cuillère il
ya beaucoup de travaux visent à vis du
handicap qui sont effectués vraiment
s'en parle enfin je pensais pas qu'ils
auraient ça et ça coûte que 200 euros ça
abordable pour tous ça permet de de voir
ce qui est accessible à la personne en
situation de handicap
voilà donc on se balade un peu partout
et on voit ce que la nouvelle
technologie peut nous proposer
tout était à commande vocale donc je ya
tout pour fermer les volets pour
éteindre le gars vous et ça j'ai trouvé
que c'était une initiative qui était
assez pertinente
surtout quand par exemple je pars vous
êtes en situation de handicap comme nous
[Musique]
en france on compte 12 millions de
personnes en situation de handicap
souffrant d'une incapacité totale ou
partielle d'activité de nombreux acteurs
se fédèrent pour trouver des solutions à
leur situation c'est le cas de jean-paul
carte à jean-paul carta bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le représentant de cartes à
bruxelles et smart mobility and devices
entreprises implantées dans les yvelines
qui a pour but de concevoir des
dispositifs adaptés afin d'améliorer la
mobilité des personnes à mobilité
réduite vous les accompagner dans leur
quotidien dans leurs loisirs parmi les
projets présentés sur le salon
le module au slider tout à fait le
module de sneijder est un projet de
dispositif aquatique qui permet la
pratique en bassin de sport qui sont
souvent malheureusement dont les
personnes handicapées en sont exclus et
qui permet de retrouver une activité
sportive ludique à la fois allongé en
toute sécurité et de pouvoir pratiquer
pour celles qui le peuvent par le biais
de leurs jambes du pédalage ou alors la
reproduction de mouvement comme dans une
salle de musculation pour les membres
supérieurs
comment vous est venue l'idée et bien en
fait par pur hasard dans une dans une
piscine une personne à mobilité réduite
se plaignaient de ne plus pouvoir jamais
faire de sport comme elle le faisait
quand elle était jeune et donc bien je
me suis mis un peu en retrait j'ai
imaginé ce dispositif que vous voyez là
aujourd'hui
vous avez également conçu des vêtements
connecter pour la prévention des
troubles musculosquelettiques la petite
choueir tout à fait le programme teacher
est un ensemble de vêtements instrumenté
ou connecté qui permet de faire de la
captation sur la posture dorsale ou
d'autres captation multi physiologique
ça peut être la température ou d'autres
choses que l'on connaît déjà et d'avoir
un rendu sur son smartphone de sa
posture et de pouvoir être accompagnés
au quotidien par un cobot un copain
robots pour le coup qui va vous
conseiller et surtout pas vous
contraindre et vous permet d'adopter les
bons gestes
t-shirt à rentrer dans votre programme
transversal hospitality tout à fait
hospital city est un ensemble de
solutions qui vont être offertes dans la
cité d'où le fait d'avoir ce nom
hospitality c'est de transférer des
compétences cliniques hospitalière dans
l'environnement de l'habitat et de tirer
ce bénéfice auprès des patients voire
des salariés quand il s'agit de la lutte
contre les troubles
musculo-squelettiques donc le module
slider comment ça marche
alors le module slider comment ça marche
donc une fois qu'il est mis en bassin
donc il est flottant et on va permettre
aux gens de pouvoir s'y mettre dedans de
manière allongé sans trop de manutention
pour les aidants ça c'est très important
puisque aujourd'hui les aidants souffre
d'une sinistralité en termes de troubles
musculo-squelettiques très importante
donc on a pensé avoir un dispositif qui
permettrait à une seule personne de
pouvoir en tenant dans les bras une
personne à mobilité réduite venir la
loge et sans aucun problème dans un
dispositif comme celui ci quand les
personnes bien sûr en un minimum
d'autonomie
elle rentre par elle-même et partant de
là elles peuvent comme on peut le voir
sur le prototype n'est déjà servir des
pédales et pédaler il n'y a aucune
résistance mécanique
il s'agit bien de votre membre le plus
atteint qui va réguler le membre le
moins atteints pour pouvoir obtenir un
déroulement du mouvement tout à fait
correct en ce qui concerne les membres
supérieurs
on a des tendeurs comme on peut
retrouver sur des éléments sportifs qui
vont permettre aux gens de reproduire
des mouvements d'étirement de poussée et
de traction et permettre aux muscles qui
sont jamais sollicité bien de retrouver
une certaine tonicité
on est sur un à sport un aspect pardon
et un apport musculaire aussi cardio
vasculaires dont le sens où il a été
testé par des cardiologues qui estime
qu'il ya un rapport sur ce sujet qui est
très important pour des gens qui ne
sortent que très rarement de leur
habitat ou voir même de leur chambre
d'hôpital
et c'est un projet adapté pour les
personnes atteintes de la maladie des
zones
alors c'est un projet qui aujourd'hui va
bénéficier d'une étude exploratoire très
particulière puisqu'on va lancer cette
étude
en partant du principe que stimuler à la
fois les muscles la vision et l'audition
par le biais d'un casque à réalité
augmentée va permettre d'amener la
personne à se stimuler et à peu trouvé
une partie de la mémoire perdue
et ça c'est tout nouveau c'est une
approche non médicamenteuses de la
maladie et on est bien sûr sur un
développement dans le temps mais qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de la couverture
de tous les médecins qui s'occupent de
cette maladie autre projet le titre erre
alors le programme petit joueur c'est
donc un ensemble de vêtements
instrumenté ou connecté pour la posture
dorsale
aujourd'hui vous voyez là la partie
haute du corps le tronc et ses capteurs
qui sont aujourd'hui alors vous êtes sur
un prototype de démonstration pour
permettre à tout le monde de comprendre
le le principe
le principe est relativement simple
pardon à partir du moment où le vêtement
a été calibré et bien quand la personne
va tenir une position dans le temps qui
est néfaste pour sa posture elle va être
informé par le biais d'un smartphone où
il ya une application qui est en cours
de réalisation avec notamment à
microsoft et avec les médecins pour
pouvoir trouver quels sont les termes
les plus compréhensible pour tout le
monde c'est un vêtement et c'est un
programme qui est à destination des
patients en post opératoire ou des
salariés pour les troubles musculo
squelettiques et grande nouveauté des
satellites vont partir dans l'espace
alors le vêtement connectés que vous
voyez là dont le principe de capture
dorsales a été retenu par le lac nyos
qui le laboratoire spatial qui était à
guyancourt dans les yvelines
et là vous avez les premières maquettes
du satellite du nano satellites qui est
un grandeur à l'échelle 1 10 centimètres
cubes et ce nano satellites va être
comment dire va recevoir à son bord nos
capteurs que l'on développe au sens de
la vie situation clinique de garches et
on va pouvoir être spatialisé c'est à
dire avoir notre certification de vol
pour accompagner l'espace une autre sur
des vols de longue durée notamment sur
la première étape qui est la lune bien
sûr pour aller et finir
en mars en ayant toujours un regard
bienveillant sur les spationautes
on estime à 1,4 million le nombre de
personnes réellement dépendantes d'ici
2020 et la barre des 2 millions sera
franchie d'ici 2040 selon le ministère
de la santé et l'insee dans les yvelines
c'est une augmentation de 64% des
personnes de plus de 80 ans qui est
prévue d'ici 2030
[Musique]
à l'occasion de la troisième édition du
salon hit onomie un bus de l'emploi se
trouve derrière moi les demandeurs
d'emploi intéressés par les services à
la personne peuvent échanger avec
l'association in vie sur les formations
et les métiers de l'aide à la personne
ils peuvent déposer leur candidature
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce 7 août société ici au
campus des mureaux à l'occasion de la
troisième édition du salon hit only
passé une très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]